how's it going I'm here where we're
gonna play gang beef the best game sense
gang beef came out of steam what were
you before okay and I'll be so hard
there we go yeah I'm already crying yes
the smoke hurts my hands
alright now grab your butt oh really
yeah
yo yo Pierce don't say yo they say Yolo
hey what are you doing me Oh where'd she
go I did not look comfortable did anyone
order X fried beer yeah yeah I got you
so good okay man what are you doing calm
down yeah so you just jump Daniel huh
yeah it's amazing
my attack mail that it's mine pushing no
don't let how much you're pleasing our
fights over fine don't know whatever you
do here but I I'm clinging on to your
budget don't poop right now because I
would fall ah ah I made the best buy
what now what are you doing here I like
this fine no doing the sound of bears
someone stop the sound
[Music]
it's grabbing the controller okay you
need to die now no no how did that
happen yeah watch this oh I got you now
there you go come on let go you don't
want to grab me I don't wanna die
come on no now I fell in the trap if you
like oh I can't beat no come on let go
see what happens good yes
strikes again the power can we get
inside the trainee sign I have sure you
don't wanna come oh my god I can't
believe you just said that yeah
oh no my gosh oh yeah like that okay
yeah place down what's gonna happen well
Lee I want you to live I'll save you go
I try to I want you to live much tell
them about my youtube channel what about
me what about me
well a new level
oh that's a nice light what do you what
we're getting sucked through be cool
yeah grab a beer ace I need to cue you
okay
you never attacked me that's how you
never kill me because I don't know the
controls now you die you die see you
later get down there see that now you
got me oh hello thanks a knife is why
never haha somebody who has a couple of
10 ax in the bullet no somebody out of
little guess now that you won oh yes yes
somebody else I'll never die Never Say
Never Never Say Never
Wow Wow one time no wake up wake up no
no my Jack oh my ass stop it hey guys
I'll be back here bring it on bring it
on I say stop running away from me you
know you can do the thing where you dunk
- right like that this is how we this is
that real bears fight come here
you want exorcism on me oh god oh god no
I slap whatever booty i won
oh no not my face what are you doing
come on Ian Owen no you were too much
heroin's everything in life if you agree
with that then like twice and if you
don't agree with that like once if you
like gang beasts and want to broke this
your but then unzip your pants and pull
them down right now bro face